extraordinary flooding and a precarious
commute in new york
the city's transport system grinding to
a halt as the tail end of what was
hurricane ida dumped record-breaking
rainfall
[Music]
the national weather service declared
the city's first ever flash flood
emergency many could hardly believe what
they were seeing look at the people
screaming and trying to get some help
what are they doing
new york's mayor described the flooding
as brutal it was also deadly a number of
lives lost across the region
in new jersey infrastructure struggled
along
residents ordered off the roads and home
to shelter as the weather closed in
a tornado adding to the destruction and
the devastating aftermath
it was pretty quick
um
wind maybe five minutes
and then
just everything was decimated
so i turned off the radio and
just heard everything there like the
roof everything collapsing so we all
jumped under the steps
scientists say that extreme heat and
rainfall are being made more likely and
more severe by climate change
oh my gosh
the astonishing and rapidly intensifying
power of hurricane ida which slammed
into louisiana just a few days ago
fueled by an unusually warm ocean
and on america's west coast wildfires
burn with increasing ferocity and
frequency
as the northeast recovers from ida there
will be much to contemplate the prospect
of more of this and how resilient our
modern world needs to be as we face the
consequences of climate change
hannah thomas peter sky news